[Musique]
et pour le retour du journal en formule
26 minutes le retour aussi de la
chronique sport de michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir danse à grégory
l'actualité de revenir sur ce plateau
bah c'est un plaisir également pour moi
alors l'actualité sportive du week-end
en tout cas les principaux résultats que
vous allez nous commenter avec notamment
du handball féminin pour commencer
direction le championnat de nationale 2
monti le bretonneux n'a pas réussi à
créer l'exploit à domicile ce samedi
soir face au quatrième du classement tôt
le carantec
le résumé du match à des images
d'aurélie ronces avantage de zellige à
l'entraîneur de montigny le bretonneux
peut se prendre la tête à deux mains ces
jeunes ne sont pas passés loin de
l'exploit contre tall carantec timide en
début de match les inhumant ten se font
bousculer à domicile et perdent
logiquement 17 à 14
al ahly temps on a eu du mal déjà dans
un premier temps à s'adapter à une set
zéro c'est à dire que ils ont fait
sortir systématiquement leur gardienne
de but pour pouvoir attaquer avec une
joueuse supplémentaire donc
on a mon a pris beaucoup de buts dans
cette situation là laisse monti le
bretonneux rectifie le tir en début de
seconde période et arrive à repasser
devant 21 à 20 à moins de 20 minutes de
la fin du match mais ce sont finalement
les joueuses de tous le carantec qui
s'imposent 30 à 26 lors de cette 14ème
journée de nationale 2 c'est toujours
quand même qu'on a bien joué mais
malheureusement il ya toujours un
gagnant et un perdant
mon analyse c'est vrai que on a
énormément été en échec face à la
gardienne de but on a trouvé des
solutions de tir mais on était aussi en
échec je pense que c'est surtout par
rapport à ça que l'on perd le match
après cette défaite montigny le
bretonneux plantes en milieu de tableau
à la 7e place du classement
la montée étant compromise le staff
travaillerait déjà sur la saison
prochaine toujours handball mais cette
fois ci chez les garçons plaisir s'est
imposé ce dimanche face à saint michel
ce sport lors de la 13e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 les pays on a
longtemps porté 23 à 21 ans classement
cette victoire leur permet de rester en
dehors de la zone de relégation à la 9e
place avec un bilan de 4 victoires pour
9 défaites depuis le début de la saison
on continue par du football américain et
le championnat de deuxième division
casque d'or les tentes ils devaient
prouver que la défaite contre les
vikings n'était qu'une erreur de
parcours les élans courtois son ton camp
très rapidement dans la partie face aux
gladiateurs de la queue-en-brie avec
deux touchdowns inscrit en avantage que
les temples y ont géré tout au long de
la partie les templiers l'emportent
finalement sur le score de 20 à 14 on
écoute la réaction de l'un des
entraîneurs
c'était une belle équipe en face qui
nous a posé quelques problèmes
on aurait pu se mettre à l'abri beaucoup
plus rapidement mais en face à une belle
équipe et maintenant c'est à nous tous à
nous d'élever le niveau maintenant avec
cette victoire les templiers d'elancourt
reste leader de la conférence nord de 2e
division à quatre victoires en cinq
matches disputés
des résultats qui permettent d'espérer
des playoffs en fin de saison une
possible montée en première division
on est là pour gagner tous les matches
et si on gagne tous les matches qu'on
est champion à la fin de l'année donc le
même objectif c'est toujours la même
chose
et là pour gagner le prochain match on
va gagner aussi on va travailler en
allemand pour bien bosser et ça va le
faire
prochain match pour les templiers le
samedi 30 mars à domicile contre les
dragons de paris et un mot rapide pour
terminer michael il y avait là les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste
alors la france est revenue avec cinq
médailles des championnats du monde qui
se sont déroulés en pologne la semaine
dernière mention spéciale à quentin
lafargue le pistard licencié au vélo
club elancourt saint quentin en yvelines
a raflé l'or sur l'épreuve du kilomètre
son premier titre mondial après le
bronze en 2016 l'argent en 2017
il va maintenant prendre des vacances
bien méritées avant de revenir au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
lui donne toutes nos félicitations merci
michael dans un instant le 7-8 sport
pour revenir sur l'ensemble de
l'actualité sportive du week-end